welcome to the aws solution architect
associate level lesson number one aws
overview
what you will learn
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to
understand an overview and the key
features of aws
trace the history of aws itself
explain the global distribution
infrastructure of aws
understand how aws became the market
leader as they currently are as well as
discuss
each aws product and service let's start
with the overview then so
amazon web services also known as aws
and in fact i might actually refer this
to aws more often because it's shorter
and
it's easier to actually pronounce it's a
secure cloud service platform it offers
cloud-based infrastructure for compute
database storage content delivery and
other functionality to help business
grow and scale
you can run hybrid application
across on on-prem um and cloud services
using aws features
and services
it has pay-as-you-go
um
pricing model which is the biggest
advantage compared to the existing net
infrastructure
you pay for what you use
from aws if i can actually pause here
for a second explain how it works
in a normal data center you basically
buy a server put it on the into the rack
and provide power provide internet
and basically the cost of this is a cost
of the box that you had to purchase in
the first place then you have a price of
the software on top of that you have a
price of a networking power cooling and
all of those features despite despite
the fact it might be the data center or
it might be in in on-prem or on your
office you always have certain costs
involved
pay as you go
is actually a totally different you
basically pay for one hour of resources
that you buy from aws you can spin up a
very small server you can spin up a very
big one but you only pay per hour that
means if you stop the server you don't
pay for it hence the first legal model
the vast array of aws products and
services allows you to build
sophisticated applications with
increased flexibility scalability and
availability
security is better than other
um
the security in the cloud is much better
than in
the on-premise
aws provides secure security
certifications and accreditation data
encryption capabilities as well as they
have exceptional hardware security
i can tell you right now that aws itself
is being such a secure platform it's
been pretty much built from grounds up
as a security
uh currently they're also providing
something called a golf cloud which is
available in us and that allows u.s
government to host a big substance of
their
government information and on the aws
itself
and it's got multiple iso certifications
security wise and it's been actually
ranked as number one security cloud
provider by gartner in 2015 and 16
which is pretty impressive
and and honestly it's it's amazing
history and evolution of aws
in this section we'll discuss how
history of aws and how it's evolved to a
current
state
so let's follow the timeline let me
so
in
let 2003
maybe make this a little bit smaller
because i went a little bit overboard
with that sugar happy
in 2003
visions for aws is presented to aws.com
in form of a paper by chris pinkham and
benjamin black
those two guys
uh went to
amazon.com which is the biggest online
reader store and presented a paper that
allowed aws amazon to use specific
services and
back in 2003
in 2004
aws released the first public service
called simple queue service
in 2006
aws officially was launched to a public
market
in 2007
over 180 000 developers signed up for
aws
in 2010
amazon.com retail web services were
moved to aws
as from 2010 actually
every single resource from amateur.com
as well as
any other local country is actually
hosted on a subset of amazon
on aws platform itself which is pretty
impressive
in 2012
uh the first reinvent conference was
held
which is now a yearly event
if you're gonna ask what re invent is i
can tell you it's extremely extremely
awesome
uh event that aws is hosting every year
the biggest one is in las vegas and it
actually happened around
two weeks ago now
actually last week happened it lasts for
a few days it's pretty much comparable
to
a
apple uh keynote that is famous around
the world and
um a reinvent is the biggest event like
this um
pretty much on the whole planet
regarding the cloud computing itself
in 2013
aws certification was released
and they started with a bunch of small
uh three certifications irc ops devops
and cloud architect
in 2015 for the first time in the
history of
aws aws actually became profitable
for as
a platform itself and it made 2.1
billion dollars in a quarter up until up
up until quarter 3 of 2015.
now
global distribution
aws has a global uh distribution and the
regions are um
are easily um let me just let's
okay
a region is
a geographical area isolated from aws
regions to provide the highest possible
fault tolerance
there are currently
13 geographical regions of which quite a
few are in the u.s
there are two regions
um
in
europe
one in ireland and one in frankfurt and
the one is coming in uk quite likely
january february 2017.
there is a single region in sao paulo
there are quite a few regions in asia
as well so total number is 13.
each region consists of um availability
zones and there are 35 of them as we
currently speak
they are present in u.s they are present
in europe as well as they're present in
asia in
asia as well as
uh sao paulo in
in in south africa
each region consists of availability
zones we call them azs and each of those
zones is basically you can think of it
as a pretty much a data center
each single region
itself consists of multiple data centers
so if we for example look at north
virginia here
the number is five that means that we
have a five physical data center in
close proximity that work together to be
able to provide almost 100 percent
uptime a downtime of a single data
center
doesn't mean that the whole region goes
down in fact it's it's not
so there are different numbers of of azs
per per region and you can actually view
this on on this particular chart as well
as you can read more on aws itself
all of the azs so i availability zones
are connected between each other
via this
super low latency fiber links and this
is what makes them so unique um
if if you distribute your for example
application in a in a region you can use
multiple acs and in this case if one
goes actually down for any particular
reason there's maybe a fault and there
is a there's a power card or some sort
of network issue your application is
still up and running very very happy in
other ac's because it's a fully
redundant solution so there is not a
single point of failure
as i mentioned before a region is a
jericho area isolated by from other
amazon regions to provide greatest
possible fault tolerance acs located
within a region with at least two per
region are connected via the low-lighted
ceilings and you can see more or less
how it works
what's worth remembering and you might
have this question on the on the exam
is
um
basically that there are always minimum
two of a availability zones per region
and that's a key design of aws not to
have a single point of failure
now
edge locations
edge locations are located in most of
the major cities around the world to
distribute the content to the end user
with reduced latency what it means is
that for example if your application is
hosted in in
in dublin on in us and your client
actually is accessing the application
maybe from from india or from china or
from
from anywhere in the world you think
they they actually
do not connect or they don't have to
connect directly across the whole world
in fact they can connect directly from
the nearest location to them and that's
the edge location which means that edge
location and the source of your
application is connected via extremely
quick fiber connection which makes it
extremely quick to load
there are multiple aws products that aws
is offering and they have a
compute storage database
analytics applications and development
services those will help you and
organization with a better speed lower
id cost and scale applications
and they're basically
divided into
into the small
sections to better understand um
how they how they actually connected so
you have a compute one and then you have
basically resources underneath you have
a storage one uh which actually has the
services regarding different things like
s3 cloud front and others you have a
developer
you have a databases you have a
networking and pretty much every other
is pretty much divided into this section
and all of those have the unique kind of
logos as well as that they have unique
name so as we go along you will be able
to actually understand much more and you
understand what all of those are for
so as i said before
aws
was named by gartner which is
actually a number one
um
review
for all the technology in the world as a
number one cloud infrastructure uh
provider
you can see aws
is actually leading with the whole uh
pool
um it's not only a leader but also it
technically and uh price efficient and
security wise all of this combined
together made it extremely extremely
agile and great hence actually it's on
on top of the board just behind of that
there's a microsoft which is a video as
well obviously with the azure as your
platform
and we have a bunch of other guys that
are trying to catch up but they're
nowhere near uh that particular um aws
itself hence
doing the certification for aws will
quite likely allow you to open yourself
to organizations um worldwide that
pretty much everyone is using nowadays
um and if they not quite like in the
next two to three years f1 will be on
the platform on the aws itself and on
the cloud itself so i can assure you
that it's amazing
great so what i will do i will actually
go through the quiz itself um
and we will basically answer this all
together so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna read the question and if everyone
can actually type their answer in in the
question and answer box that would be
absolutely great i can see already
people ask answering the question
which is which is great
how many uh
geographical regions aw has a10 b13
33 d 190
i can see
13 13 13 13 13 pretty much everyone
the correct answer is b
13 that's correct 13 geographical
regions 35 azs and it's available in 190
countries great job guys that's
absolutely great
next question is what is the minimum
number of azs also known as avadabidi
zones within a region
answer a5 answer b 33 answer c 3 answer
d
2.
okay i can see the answers
okay so
i see
the correct answer is d number two i can
see that few people well majority of you
answered d which is great and i see also
that
ash ashok and charajit answered 3 and
also 33.
i'm going to explain that that's the
wrong answer but i'm going to explain
why
minimum amount of azs also known as
availability zones is two the reason for
it
is
in order to be fully redundant not to be
not to have a single point of failure or
presence you need at least two points
and aws provides at least two azs in
every single region to make sure that
your application or whatever you're
deploying that is fully available in
case something goes wrong with one of
the data centers 2 is absolute minimum
however if the data center provides more
feel free to go for even more to be able
to achieve even greater uptime
so the correct answer is 2 d
i can see the challenges saying as per
aws site latest is 40 ac's and 15 uh geo
uh
regions
that that's correct however the
certification itself is still not
updated and aws itself didn't update
their own questions yet because they
introduced those ac's not that long ago
and up until they they release
the the latest uh
the batch we still
working with exactly what we have here
and it's still extremely valid and it
will be for next two years so we don't
really know when aws will actually
change their questions uh
in the in the future it takes them some
time to do that but
for the purpose of this particular
course and certification
the the the
the answers and numbers here are pretty
much correct but yes
you're absolutely uh
right about that and they they recently
introduced that
let's give to another question
which aws product uses edge locations
to provide cdn service
aws ec2 aws web services
amazon cloudfront or none of the above
that's
pretty much
great
so
majority of you answered uh c
the correct which is the correct answer
that's absolutely correct i can see a
few people answered d none of the above
and also one person answered aws
um now
the correct answer is cloudfront
um
the edge locations whenever you hear
edge locations it's always cloudfront
the reason for it is it's available in
over 190 uh
countries um and and pretty much that's
that's the service we'll talk about it
more uh in the in the in the future as
discussing what is actually used for and
how it's useful
so the correct answer is c amazon
cloudfont
next question oh let's actually end up
the questions um i would say great guys
so far pretty much solid um
no worries if you answered wrong we are
here here to learn and that's exactly
what we're trying to achieve i'm pretty
sure you're gonna hear this question
next time i'm gonna answer correctly so
great job let's let's let's go further
so
overview of aws products and services in
in this section we will get an overview
of all the products products and
services that aws platform has to offer
so
let's start
with compute section
which is exactly here
so what is compute
the elastic
elastic compute cloud which also is
known as the ec2 from
amazon provides resizable compute
capacity in the cloud which is intended
to make a web scale computing easier for
developers
users maintain complete control of their
computing resources
amazon and amazon operates under a
pay-as-you-go model as i actually
mentioned before
it also takes minutes to obtain and boot
new server instances
so it allows you to for quick scaling
and and actually complete recommends
change
so that's easy too
in fact you're gonna hear easy to quite
a lot and every single uh system that
you ever will build will always consist
of ec2
and
easy to if you think about it what it is
it's basically a server it's it's it's
it's a server it's an instance
we also call it an instance because
you only
you only need the server for specific
tasks for example you need to
have a web server and
a web server consists let's say of of a
server itself so where the application
is running and you have a database so
what you'll need for that is a one ec2
instance so in this particular case
server that you'll be able to spin up or
launch or boot as we also call it and
that will provide you the the computing
capacity
which you can put os on top and you can
have any application you want to to to
to to actually host in this case
obviously we mentioned a
web server and that's pretty much what
aws ec2 is
also aws provides a service also known
as ec2 container service also known as
ecs
what it is is a highly scalable high
performance container management service
that supports docker containers and
allows you to easily run applications on
managed clusters of
aws ec2 instances
um
it's worth mentioning that it's not
featured in the solutions architect
associate exam it's mainly for your uh
for your knowledge um at the moment but
it's not gonna be during the exam itself
i have a question here from charanjit as
aws solution architect do
one has to deal with all the features of
aws it's a very good question uh
the short answer is no um
the longer you work with aws quite
likely you need to be exposed to more
and more
uh
so different solutions and different
approaches and this is where you start
researching different um
services that aws has to offer when i
started working at aws i primarily use
ec2 s3 and and and pretty much that's it
and
over the years where the demand for
different solutions different
architectures and and different
requirements actually grew i started
using different ones because it was much
easier to do it this way
and the maintenance as well as
as as the pricing model was extremely
extremely good
so
um
i can i can assure you that uh
the longer you work with aws you'll know
more and more and start using more
services but i don't know a single
person and i've worked with loads and
loads of people i also work very close
with aws and i can assure you that not a
single person knows all of those
services because there's so many of them
and it's actually almost impossible to
know all of them
yes i can i can hear i can hear a few
questions uh regarding the docker and um
if we can elaborate a little bit about
the ecs itself now i can mention a
little bit i don't want to go into deep
too much into the subject because it's
not going to be on the exam itself i'm
going to just mention it so we we can
move on quicker
docker
does everyone know what docker is
if no i will explain a little bit about
docker and i don't want to again going
too much detail into that um
so
okay ankar doesn't know
docker is is basically a an application
a system that allows you to
run services in the containers so think
of it as you have os running so a server
with a one um
let's say windows server or a linux
server it doesn't really matter what
flavor you have and then
on top of that you install docker and
docker can manage multiple applications
within as a little containers
and you can run multiple of those
on one box which makes
the box much better because you can
actually utilize the full potential of
the box rather than run one application
on top of the os which is very very um
inefficient
the question here is it like a vmware
no it's not it's not a virtualization
it's not a uh
um basically
it's not because it runs this
application itself
so
ecs itself
is basically a service that harvests uh
amazon ec2 instances
and allows you to run multiple
applications
on top of the os in a very tiny um
sections
so it is a multi-up monitor that's
absolutely correct and the video of ecs
as well as docker it allows you to
actually copy and paste them across
pretty much any other server and it's
fully uh
it's fully compatible which means you
can run it anywhere on any hardware
because it's independent which means as
long as you have a docker and the
application runs in docker you can run
it on multiple oss you can run it on
multiple hardwares in multiple locations
that's the beauty of a docker
so i hope i answered your question and
i'd like to move to
next slide if it's okay with you guys
now we're gonna discuss a little bit
about aws elastic bin stock
now aws elastic beam stock is easy to
use service for developing and scanning
web applications and services deployed
via java.net php node.js and many other
languages out there
also including docker um that can run
applications something like apache nginx
passenger and
iis
you can upload your code to um to
to beanstalk then aws will inspect it
and
it will then provision the resources in
order to run it what it means it's a
fully automated
system administration so all you need to
do as a developer for example
is that
you upload your code then it's get
validated and then all the resources
needed for the application to run will
be allocated to that
and you have a fully running application
without worrying about
compute
resources memory and number of servers
it's fully managed which is absolutely
great
um
let's move a little bit further
it again is lambda
aws lambda lets you run your code
without provisioning or managing servers
you pay for the compute
and execution time
basically what lambda is is a serverless
compute what it means is if you have a
code
you can basically
run a small self-contained snippet
something like a java js or python or
any other
language you you want the list is
available on on aws website what it
supports and recently they announced
even more languages that it supports
and
basically
you only
execute the code
whenever you need it so all you're going
to pay for
is
running time of your application
it's it's you don't need any servers for
this you don't need any resources you
don't need any memory and all you're
going to pay
is the amount of time your application
is running to perform its operation
i i don't have to tell you how awesome
it is and i can actually give you
real-time example of of
of a lambda itself we had a customer
that had a a job running overnight
and the job was pretty much simple was
basically taking uh excel
feed from one of the documents and
parsing it and pretty much converting
this into
another excel with a report it was
old-fashioned and they had two servers
running
in order to to do this because it was a
z solution which means those servers
needed to be
fully operational hence there they had
two of them
the problem was that the client was a
little bit unhappy because the cost of
running those servers in the data center
as well as running having people running
those servers and cleaning all of that
was about uh 1500 us dollars
just for the job that took maybe 30
seconds to actually do
to perform and i get it out of that it
was fully it was fully automated so it
was actually very good
so what we've done instead we use lambda
which we actually converted the code of
the client which still has the same
functionality with the exception of it
runs out automated via lambda
and it executes does everything needs to
do and outputs the file exactly the same
format and it had to do before
now the cost for tax was slashed from
around fifteen hundred dollars to more
or less five us cents
a month
yes that's 0.05
for a whole month to perform the same
job
as two servers were running
lambda itself is also fully uh
redundant
and when we showed the cost to the
customer he couldn't believe that the
bill can be so low and i see a response
from you already which is correct it's
amazing and if you can use the service i
would actually encourage you to do that
i have a question back and does it a
user shared service uh
back-end does it use your shared service
t to run a code
uh yes
basically what lambda is is aws
spare resource running on ec2 in a in a
pretty much automated fashion that all
you need to do is upload
a code and they will execute this code
on the servers behind
for you it's a fully managed which means
you don't have even access to that all
you need to do is basically
upload the code and tell
the lambda what the code needs to do
and based on that um the only resource
it runs and is using is the amount of
seconds or milliseconds that your
application is actually running
and pretty much that's it so it is using
aws ec2
servers behind that
on which data it runs this function
um i don't actually understand the
question on which data it runs this
function
uh
can you actually uh
explain a little bit more if possible so
i can
ask answer your question
the code if it
is generate the
sorry generate the report
um
so what what we've done is we basically
rewrote this uh the application itself
which was um
uh i believe it was
uh
i think was a little java application uh
as far as i remember and basically what
we've done is basically we wrote it to
work with the lambda to make sure that
it it's pulling from correct sources and
outputs to the correct um
target so we we pretty much have the
same uh flow of of of of the application
itself
so it was using java just to answer your
question but any other language that is
supported can be used as well and also
you can convert a code from one language
to another if you feel stronger for
example with python or js
you can convert the current one into the
language you prefer and have exactly the
same output so
so you can achieve the same thing
so basically what lambda does is a
function called
um
yeah i would say as long you can you can
kind of think of it like that
lambda e executes a code that you wrote
so as long as you can
write your specific function or or
requirement in in language that lambda
supports lambda can do it and
there are limitations of that like for
example if you need to
ask lum to perform multiple
huge data pools from uh for multiple
databases across the whole world maybe
it's not the the greatest out maybe then
limit this to a smaller chunks and and
do it a little bit differently and maybe
use more dedicated hardware for that but
it's amazing when you have a smaller
automated tasks um
and and the cost saving on that is
extremely extremely amazing
um
okay i have another question does lambda
require data to be stored in aws
environment or this can be stored in in
your dc
it's actually a very good question now
we're going to get to this a little bit
later
but you can link your dc with eclipse
resources via either vpn or you can link
it via direct connect
and what it will do it will extend a
network for your on-premise or data
center into the aws itself and so aws
itself can fetch data from your data
center or on-prem as it would actually
be working locally so think of it as
extension of your data center rather
than an additional
data center that you currently
use
i have another question
um
data can data be pulled from the
so the data can be from anywhere
we will have to link that to our db
uh wherever it is it's it's
um
lambda gets
yes data can be obtained pretty much
from anywhere as long as you write this
within your function because lambda does
have functions to actually pull the data
from different sources uh
you need to remember that by default
lambda is only allowed to pull the data
from within aws itself so as long as you
have the data there it's absolutely
great if you don't you need to extend
this via the
vpn or
direct connect in order for them to
extend the reach of the data itself for
your function to work um
that's that's great so
um
i would say we can focus on the lambda a
little bit more later so i can explain
all those uh features and functions um
let's move on maybe to another slide
which will allow us to uh
to move on a little bit
and we will come back to london later
and you have probably more detailed
questions at the later stage so let's
move on
another one
is
elastic load balancing also known as elb
what it is it's a networking service
that automatically spreads out incoming
application traffic across several
ec2 instances
customers have option to enable elb
within a single ac
or throughout multiple zones
that service is uh can also detect
unhealthy instances
and reroute the traffic in case of uh to
the healthy ones
uh elb
uh basically is black and white balancer
like a physical balancer so if you have
let's say two servers
that um
that are
uh working
in front of elb let's say
in the normal scenario you would
probably need to deploy some sort of
device in front that when the traffic
comes in it kind of can root the traffic
in some sort of way to both of your
servers we use eobs when you're trying
to achieve higher
availability or or uptime so in case one
server goes down
the elb itself sorry the load balancer
itself can detect that and can
push traffic only towards a single box
which means
for the user itself it shouldn't be
a downtime because one box can handle
quite likely more than
more traffic uh and it's uh it's it's
basically redundancy uh implemented so
what we currently have
in aws we call it elastic load balancing
and what it is is a service because it
it's not physical
device that you need to purchase and put
it in front is actually a software
written that it can root your traffic in
between the instances so basically you
have multiple instances you'll be
uh basically roots the traffic towards
them as pretty much as we mentioned here
and
and what happens if any of those
instances actually is unhealthy or died
or something happened uh elb itself will
detect that will stop serving traffic to
uh to the instances and the affected
ones and it will root the traffic only
to the instances that are healthy when
those instances become healthy again it
will do specific checks that i can
discuss with you guys later
and it will enable them again
and start within the traffic
automatically
so i have a question can help also run
in around robin mode also if it supports
ssl offloading for uh web apps uh 200 is
a very very good question um
i will answer this
in
uh two answers one about one robin and i
other one about ssl well round robin is
is is a technology that allows it to
equally distribute the traffic between
two
locations and yes since pretty much
aws introduced the round robin style uh
routine
because before they didn't have it and
particular traffic was pretty much one
to one so whatever goes to one server
goes to other but the problem was that
when you had a service on one side that
were let's say bigger boxes
and on the other side you had a smaller
boxes for any purpose the amount of
traffic going towards both of them was
pretty much equal which means the
instances with a bigger
more uh performance were getting less
utilized and the smaller instances or
server sizes were over utilized which
means they were working kind of over
time and since 2013 uh aws introduced
round robin style um feature um that
allows you to actually root the traffic
equally to all of the boxes no matter
what the size so it will detect how busy
there are and it will actually spread
the traffic equally you can also enable
additional features onto this which i
will actually discuss uh
with you later and what kind of features
are available but yes it's it's
available now regarding the ssl itself
yes the eob itself supports full
ssl sorry for my writing i'm not an
artist
what it is is you can upload your
certificate directly to a eob itself and
all the traffic from pretty much uh
internet itself
uh going to elb
will go via the http
s
which means it's fully encrypted now elb
itself
and the connection between elb and
instances is not encrypted you can
enable this if you want
for additional security but that's all
within the network
restricted network itself which means
there is no need for that all you need
to do is upload certificate in the
single point into the eob itself and the
rest is fully encrypted so it's actually
amazing because you only need one
certificate you don't need hundreds of
certificates for all those servers and
if you're spinning multiple new
instances all of them using exactly the
same certificate behind
um i have another question how low
advancing will check whether my
application is down or not let's assume
server is not done but the application
which is running on the instance is done
how it will detect this well it's a very
good question it's a very very valid one
as well um
aws itself has a few tracks it can run a
http check which means it will check for
a response let's say 200 from the web
server
it has a tcp style checks which can
check if the port is responsive which
means for example if your application if
you're trying just to
check if maybe ssl is responsive because
that's all you need to do you can set up
a tcp on port 22 and if for example any
server is is off or ssl is not
responsive then tcp check will fail and
the instance will be removed from elb
and the traffic will stop flowing there
in case of web servers
you can use http style checks which
means if you have any other response
then 200 to a link that you are
specified on the uh on the elb itself
then
it will actually detect for example 404
page doesn't exist or you might not even
have response at all what will happen in
this case is
it will detect this and it will remove
this particular server from the pool
because it's affected
so i hope i answered your question here
um
instance means it's server instance yes
uh
yes sorry i'm i'm using the instance uh
word so much i i worked within the aws
for past seven years and one once you
started working you you pretty much
never call server servers anymore you
call them instances the reason behind it
is because you don't treat them as a
servers you actually use them and
decommission and use and reuse basically
you you treat them like a box of tissues
you only need a server for specific
tasks you use it and then you do
commission and you pretty much do the
same so we call them instances and the
reason for it is it's it's it's reusable
you don't pay for a hardware anymore you
don't need to use the same server over
and over again all you need to use is
the same server
only for the purpose of a specific job
once it's done delete terminate and you
can spin up a new one straight after
so that's pretty much
the answer to your question
another question is does the application
need to keep the hardware communication
with elb
yes um it does however the heartbeat
itself is originating from elb itself
not from application which means the
heartbeat itself either via the tcp or
http originates from eob and goes
towards the instance it pings every few
seconds and
and that determines if um elb its elb
itself can connect to the instance
itself and there are a number of fault
uh folds that um and failures that we
can accept beyond which it can remove
the instance uh from the poor if it's
unhealthy
another question does it support session
uh
stickiness
yes
that's a very very good question eob
does support session stickiness which
means you're gonna pick basically one
box in um in a in an elb setting which i
can show you later on during the session
that once we actually gonna discuss eob
in detail and what it means that if for
example user
uh
goes through elb
and has let's say a a session open that
keeps their basket running so for
example someone went to amazon.com and
you have your basket in in the top
corner that you have running quite
likely you went to the elb and you
allocated one of the instances that
keeps this state of your of your basket
now what would happen if you would go to
other server suddenly you wouldn't have
the basket because that particular
basket here doesn't have your info
what would you need to do is enable
session stickiness which means every
single time this particular user is
requesting an update from the basket
that does anybody operation it goes
through exactly the same path and always
ends up on the same server so yes it
does support that
another question
uh can we extend elbs per load
requirement to our service yes that's
actually um it's it's the whole point of
using eob is to be able to scale
vertically rather than horizontal uh
sorry scale horizontally rather than
vertically what it means is you have a
single elb
and
you have a pretty much uh
internet connecting to it so basically
it comes with a website
and in this packet website
let's say you have two servers running
yeah
now what it means is to the user
always
only elb is visible
no matter how many servers you have
behind
only elb is visible
what it means is
um in case for example that you have
let's say 50 of traffic flowing just
because it's a let's say
not very busy day
you need only two servers which is
absolutely fine all of them will get
obviously fifty percent of traffic
each because they're running in the in
the in the
in the around robin mode and
and that's absolutely fine but imagine
what happens is there's a sale or or
there is a there is a peak of traffic or
someone actually someone posted
something and there is a spike of
traffic on your website and it goes to
100 sorry 100 yeah what will happen then
is you can set up it will be in the way
that it can add
additional servers which means the
traffic suddenly drops from 50 here to
only 25 per box
and
all the server pool can now handle much
more traffic and there's almost
virtually no a limit to how many servers
you can have so you can spin up as many
as you want or you can have as many as
one i would always highly encourage you
to have always at least two servers
behind eob because obviously a service
can go down and up and and it's just
basically a hardware that can that can
have a failure but
running at these two servers in in
behind the elb is the most efficient and
the most
amazing way because it will allow you to
have amazing uptime as well as you can
scale up whenever needed or scale down
if you don't need it and save money
another question i have
um
another additional question i have is
the
traffic within the elb network after the
elb is sent in the clear does this uh
does it pose any security issues
um the answer to your question is yes
and no
now
we all know that within the region you
have multiple ac's what it means is that
you have multiple data centers now if
you have an elb that means that quite
likely if you want to spin let's say
three different servers in all three
days to have a full redundancy
the network and the request will go
between data centers now the data
centers are connected via super quick
fibers which is not encrypted so if for
example you have um
if for example you have uh one day
let me make it a little bit smaller
sorry for that
if you have let's say one data center
here and why the way that why one data
center here the connection between them
is not encrypted whatsoever which means
anything behind elb that goes to both of
those data centers is not everything
that is before eob is fully encrypted if
you enable ssl obviously you can
actually enable ssl on on all on all of
those data centers and make sure that
the eob itself and all the instances
behind are talking and the good news is
that you don't need a fully signed
certificate to do that you're going to
have self-signed certificate because as
long as it's fully encrypted within
the eob doesn't care if it's if it's
fully fully signed or no all people will
see is the certificate that actually
sits in front of eob itself which means
it's great
is disaster recovery recovery enabled in
this system
uh
it can be
um we have a feature called self uh
healing or also also known as auto
recovery you can specify you can specify
that any instance behind in the pool um
once it's it's dead
let's say this particular box died
behind elb
what happens is
this particular box
if you'll be detected that this
particular box is dead and you set up
that a minimum amount of service i want
is let's say two what happens is this
box can be determined or terminated
automatically and the new box in its
place can be created
and
traffic can bother me
rooted here so yes it can
be enabled
i see we have quite a few questions
regarding elb um i would say
maybe
let's leave maybe the rest of the
questions if possible
and
i want to we actually read
eob itself because i'm sure you have
more than that and quite likely i'm
going to give you amazing uh real life
scenarios what actually happens in
specific cases and how we use it and
when um and then you can based on that
but you can ask more questions um that's
just a little bit of overview and i
really didn't want to dig into much
because i can answer other questions
trust me on that and we can talk for
hours maybe even days which would be
awesome
so
if we may we finished just now
on the elb of what it is and we went
into details of different features
um and and and and settings
uh people are asking which is
which is which is great um
i can see another question already
you'll be rooting the request to
instances um
i would say
if you can keep this question for now we
will discuss that particular question on
how it actually works
in the detailed section and probably on
the
section tomorrow
where we're going to be discussing ec2
and it will be in much greater detail so
if you can remove this question that
would be absolutely great at this
concept i would like to just go through
overview which which we are trying to
focus on
and then we're gonna move to a much
detailed uh material later on and pretty
much probably gonna have even more
questions than that
so
let's move on
now we're moving into the
directory of storage and content
delivery
so you will be able to find it in aws
console um under the storage storage and
content delivery you have different uh
services underneath you have an s3 you
have you have s3
you have a cloud front you have elastic
file system glacier snowball and few
others and i'll discuss this with you
pretty much
right now
so
aws
simple storage service also known as s3
pretty much nobody is using a long name
simple storage service
um while working in aws because we are
trying to use the s3 shortcut as much as
possible as well as ec2 as well as as
vpc and other ones that you have out
there i will pretty much on every single
occasion we have a new service in
introduced what we will do is
we will
describe what it is and from this moment
onwards i will use the shortcut as well
as occasionally i will also mention the
full name so you remember that and
you'll be able to associate this with
the shortcut itself
i have a question why cdna is available
with storage section in aws it's a very
good question
the store the cdn is available because
it is a part of aws it's service called
cloud front which allows you to
basically host
files to to to users as we discussed
available in over 190 countries and it
is a part of um the storage because
it is linked directly to the s3 uh when
you create a bucket you can then
um s3 bucket which is the storage itself
which i
will give you idea later you'll be able
to create a cloud fund out of that which
means all the content of this bucket
will be distributed globally in the same
time which means it's available as a
content delivery network
so i will go into this detail in in in a
bit let me discuss the simple storage
service first what it is is an
object-based online storage service that
offers unlimited data storage space in
the cloud
what it is it's
it's a place to store all your files
it's as simple as that you can store
images you can store other assets for
websites you can keep backups you can
keep you can basically share files
between service servers and different
services that you're hosting
and it can also host static websites
additionally many aws services write and
read from s3 and that's basically
a description of what it is
um
s3 itself is probably one of the most
important after ec2 uh service that you
you probably will need to know or want
to know is because it's used everywhere
and every single time every single time
you need to write something to a to a
file
you can write it on the server but if
you have a two servers that need to
share something quite likely s3 is part
of your solution also for backups and
for storing any data
s3 will be used and that's a key feature
of that
um so
let's move to the next slide
um
storage and content delivery so
cloudfront
cloudfront is a content delivery service
also known as a cdn that i actually just
explained also in the previous question
that integrates with other amazon's
cloud services to provide easy way for
businesses and developers to distribute
data
through high speed transfers
you can make a website load faster by
spreading a static file delivery to be
closer to the to the user where
use when used globally
of a network of uh pretty much all the
edge locations what it means is as i
described before if you for example
connecting to the to the uh to the
service in u.s and you're connecting
let's say from asia then the latency
obviously between those two locations uh
let me just try to doodle it a little
bit for you so that's let's say us and
that's asia
and i know that they don't look like a
circles right now but that's just for
the purpose of this particular session
so if your server is actually hosted in
a in the us this is where your box is
and your clients are connecting from
india itself let's say what means is
that the connection is pretty much going
over pretty much all the countries all
the way to the us hence the latency and
the delay of uh how quick you can obtain
the data from the server is slower
because it needs to travel pretty much
across the whole globe to be able to to
to to request something from your server
now what cdn is is a point or location
nearest to the user that will be able to
obtain specific file instead of trying
to get the same file from the server so
initial connection might be still to the
to the server itself but then if the
server says hey i want you to actually
fetch a file called
abc.jpg because that's my logo or
something instead of you your browser
going all the way to the us and trying
to fetch this from this particular box
what it actually says is hey actually
you know what i have this file in here
so why don't you just go there and just
fetch this file and that way
uh there i can see here as well as the
time needed for for for for your web
browser any other application uh to get
the particular file is reduced
hundreds of times and actually not only
that but also number of requests hitting
the web server here is reduced because
nothing actually hits this after initial
connection which means all the files can
be obtained from that particular spot
which is great and you can have this
particular file or copy of this in
190 locations around the world which
means no matter where the connection is
coming from quite likely there's
something nearby to get the data from
and that's exactly what the cdn is it's
it's amazing i used it multiple times it
allows allowed us to actually have a
service that are much much smaller
because you don't need people to obtain
the data from the servers anymore they
just basically obtain the structure of
the website let's say
so the index file and the csv
and then the rest like images and all
the pngs and everything else you can
think of is actually grabbed from the
nearest location and also you can share
different files like pdfs and pretty
much word documents from those locations
which means people don't do not download
those files across the world they don't
own them locally which actually works
for them much much quicker and the
transfers are insane because they are
local
now
next service is called
elastic file system
what it is is
elastic file system is a network
attached storage also known as nas in
the cloud it's been introduced probably
around a year ago and it's a storage
that can be attached to multiple ec2
instances so basically multiple servers
it provides block level storage
currently it's only available in preview
in lws
u.s west region it doesn't
feature
regularly in exam at the moment however
later it will now it's it's worth
mentioning that's a new feature that aws
came up because so far people were
complaining about that ec2 instances
cannot share data yes you can upload
data to s3 which is great but s3 is not
it's it's not block level it's object
storage which is very important and the
difference between those two is block
storage can be indexed your system can
know what files are there object storage
cannot be indexed which means the data
you can upload there and the data is
persistent however the system cannot
know where the file is what it means is
that you'll need a specific link or
specific path
in order to get data out of s3
and on block level uh which is elastic
file system you don't because the system
can actually use a
normal explorer or or command line and
you can actually see the content of the
file while in s3 you cannot so aws came
up with this block level storage which
basically is also called elastic file
system now you can you can basically
create elastic file system which is a
which is a storage and attach it to any
instance you want and and a good example
of using it here would be
if for example you have
a
maybe a web server or or anything like
this all you have is bunch of files that
you always want to have available
and no matter how many servers you want
to spin up you always want to make sure
that all those servers have access to
the same files
which means you attach
efs
to all three of them it's a central
point
and it works like this now at any stage
any of those instances will be able to
access the files will be able to change
them and the instance to other systems
is instant which means
the change happens straight away
so
uh you need to make sure that
when you're writing application is that
there are not that many like not too
many changes to one file at the same
time because it takes a little bit of
delay and if let's say you have a pool
of 100 servers in in your in your
application and all of them are writing
to one file well
application can go a little bit confused
because it takes a little bit of time
before the file gets uh synced or
updated we're talking him about
milliseconds so we're not talking about
seconds minutes or even hours we're
talking about milliseconds but imagine
that all those hundred servers are
required requesting the same file
changing the same file
100 times seconds times 100 you can
imagine how much traffic there is and
quite likely the application will maybe
even crash or slow down so you need to
make sure you understand that and you
can use it and you can share specific
data but if you need to perform a lot of
operations um on on a specific file i
would encourage you to maybe uh store
the file locally and perform those on
each single server so it doesn't affect
essential storage it's pretty much the
same as saturating
a network link to a single mass server
and in this case
obviously more you request so it gets up
until it stops so
so this is how it works uh i can also
answer two questions and
as you said efs is nas
so how the block level storage is nas
our file uh level storage come from
or come from
fillers basically
the question is about uh
from uh
challenged the question is uh either
it's a block
or file level storage
it is a block level storage which is
which is the the lowest form possible uh
that means that the system can actually
write any file to it can have a system
on it and pretty much can even run off
it
uh fire level system is one step beyond
when you can only write the files and
pretty much that's it you cannot run a
system of a
file uh level storage itself um
so pretty much and i put
all the servers will have access to each
block of the drive
in a full permission which means they
can operate and do any operation so if
you for example want to run a full av
scan you have access to every single
potential block of this storage which
from my point of view is pretty much
like any other hardware that you have in
your in your computer you can do
anything to it you cannot actually run
os or you can run anything of your nas
or like in the living room maybe or in
the data center you cannot because it is
dedicated like this yes you can run
vmware's and you can have ice skies and
all of that but on the on the block
level that's the closest you can get to
a actually visible hard drive in your
computer or in your server while
actually being on the network
um
[Music]
another question is how does dfs
distribute the data across clusters
um
it's it's it's actually
it's it's simple it actually doesn't
have a clusters what it means is
it creates a single
let's say shared folder that is
available and all you need to do is
basically map this packet folder to all
of your servers it's a single central
location for all your files
um and and
basically that's it
so that's as simple as this
um
i have another question regarding uh
respect to the large files um
[Music]
regarding the the large files i will
give you all the breakdown of all of
that um
in in the future however in the future
section
sessions however uh at this current
stage elastic file system
is not on the exam itself
and
you quite likely will not have any
questions from it um i don't want to
commit too much time towards that
because i would like to focus more on
the stuff that will be on exam
i'm more than happy to answer your
questions in fact i encourage you
after the session itself to ask any
question you want on honor simply
simply talk or submit a ticket and you
will get a full
response with the links and everything
else and chat on the forum and you'll
get loads of responses there
every single question you have i'm
pretty sure there's answer for it and
i'm more than happy to give it to you
today because the session is only four
hours i would like to do as much as we
can um and
you know to cover as much as we can
so sorry if i cannot answer all the
questions i tried just a few
so let's move on if possible
another one another service is that
people have discussed today is called
amazon glacier what amazon glacier is is
a long-term backup and archiving service
in in the cloud
it takes backups uh of uh it takes
backups of your backups that you keep on
the s3 however you should refer to
refrain from retrieving data in a hurry
what it means is as simple as this
imagine that you have a s3
bucket
yeah
you have a s3 bucket
that you
doing all of your backups from all the
places in the world or from all the
servers let's say around the world
that's great now f3 itself is a very
good as a storage itself
and it's extremely extremely redundant
it actually has got
99.99
in fact after the dot the 11 nines of
how good it is which is which means that
one file probably will be lost every uh
something like a 300 years maybe out of
every single file you have upload which
is insane and it's replicated globally
which is actually replicated within a
region which means between multiple uh
data centers which is almost impossible
to use your file however i don't want to
go into details in that
because i want to explain a glass here
what blaster is you can set up a
glassier vault it's called the glassy
vault which will actually take all the
files from s3 that you currently have
and push it to the vault
yeah
and that's a uh
i'm gonna call it glass here
now
that particular that particular um
behavior can be scheduled can be
automated you can set up a specific
policies on this three saying any file
that is older than let's say 30 days i
want this to go to glacier and the
reason why we would want to do this is
because for aws um
is it's pretty cheap um i would need to
fetch the latest numbers because those
numbers actually recently changed around
a week ago and now they became something
something like a 32 percent cheaper so i
don't want to give you the the wrong
numbers just to give you an idea but the
principle is that let's say for the sake
of this exercise but the cost of
aws is 0.03 yeah it's less but let's
just say that i can assure you that the
glacier cost is 0.001
three it's ten times cheaper per gig
which means if you have a lot of storage
that you you you you use on this three
and lots of files that you keep them as
a backups i would actually encourage you
to keep everything in the class here
because it's going to be 10 times
cheaper for you the only downtime of
cluster itself is uh that when you're
trying to restore data and that's the
biggest difference between s3 and and
and glacier is that
it takes up to uh
between four and six hours for the data
to be available because what aws will do
is probably they will take tapes or
backups or something somehow and restore
all the data from some sort of source
nobody really knows what it is because
it's a top secret
aws um service
and what they will do is they'll restore
and make it available back to the s3
which means after that you can connect
to s3 and fetch all your data
and that's pretty much it and that's the
secret so if you ever hear any questions
on the exam that you probably discussed
later
regarding that i wanna archive stuff i
want to keep it for long and
i don't want to really access you know
um to my files straight away glasses is
quite like the answer because it's a
extremely cheap and it's a long-term
storage solution and it's a backup of a
backup basically
so that's what the laser is
um
let's move on a little bit
further if we can
now
we have another service called aws input
export snowball
which is a part of the import export
service used to move large amounts of
data quickly without using the network
okay now what it actually is and what
what does it do
okay imagine situation you have a data
center
uh let's say i'm gonna draw a data
dc
and in your data center let's say you
have
i don't know let's let's let's call it
gigabytes of data yeah
now
that's maybe not a lot which is which is
fair enough you might have a thousand or
you might have a million just for the
sake of the exercise
now in order to send this data to s3
normally
you would basically connect your dc to
s3 bucket
s3
via the internet and depending how far
the pipe is
and how quick it is
you will then have to wait depending on
how much data as well it is you need to
wait maybe minutes maybe hours maybe
days maybe even months in some cases i
can assure you maybe even years for this
data to actually go over
and not always everyone's got
yes to wait for the data to be sent and
sometimes when you have a migration
process like i want to migrate all my i
don't know all my files into the data
from the data center to the to the to
the um
to the s3 so the cloud you might have a
situation that
the files actually are changing and
there are more and more files because
it's a live production environment and
if you're going to start uploading those
files
they will never finish because the
amount of data probably are being added
to amount of data being sent to s3 is
more which means
you know this process can take years and
depending on your on your line as well
if you have
you know if you're lucky enough to have
like one gigabit line
uh
that's great
sorry from uh it's my mouse uh one
gigabit line that's great but if you
only own let's say 10 megabits or maybe
one megabit connection or even adsl
trust me
you will never upload those files to the
s3 now this is where snowball comes in
what snowball actually is it's a
physical appliance
it's actually a box a size of i'd say
medium-sized carton box that it can be
carried around it's i've seen one before
it's pretty much awesome and what it is
is aws will send you this project box
to your office or home or wherever you
need it
then you connect this particular box to
your infrastructure you can connect by
the fiber you can connect via the
network you can connect via the there
are different ports on it you can read
much more information i'm just giving
you a little bit of overview of what it
is and then
what you do is upload all your files
locally via the fastest possible way
onto the box so it's like basically they
send you a big big hard drive
and
all you need to do once you upload it
you basically
call aws and there's a label on it you
call it a aws
carrier they come they take the box and
the same they deliver this to the data
center all that aws does is connects
this to their uh
to their infrastructure and downloads
all those files that you just uploaded
into the s3 bucket
yeah
and that takes maybe
three days if you think about it if you
if you have let's say obviously that
depends on the amount of data you have
so one day you will get the you will get
the appliance you upload the all the
files second day
pretty much delivery happens and the
third day all your files are available
if you have obviously better bytes of
data then it quite likely will take
longer than that i can assure you but
it's doable via the hard drive rather
than send via internet and that's what
pretty much snowball is i can tell you
off of the record a little bit
that around week ago
on the brain band
aws introduced a new thing uh called
snow mobile
i can assure you that's not gonna be on
the exam because it's such a new thing
that it's uh it's it's uh
it just basically was released what snow
mobile is is the upgraded version of a
snowball and what it is
i'm gonna draw it here
it is
it is a truck with a trailer basically
what it is is they drive this thing into
your data center they connect it via
multiple fiber links and that particular
thing is uh is capable of storing
exabytes of data we're talking exabytes
now we're not getting gigabytes
petabytes we're talking exabytes or data
that's a container that is huge
they bring it to your data center they
connect it to everything you can upload
the data then they drive it to aws and
they do exactly the same thing over and
over again so it's not a small portable
it's a whole truck
so that's obviously
a bear in mind if you have a huge data
center migration maybe instead of having
hundreds of those
just to be able to do that maybe it's
easier to just call it obvious and say
send me one of those
but that's just for your interest and i
hope that was interesting and we can
move on to the next slide
now
what do we have in next is a storage
gateway what it is is used to increase
the capacity to store files such as word
documents for example
also you can
keep any other files it also simplifies
the process of file retrieval from your
corporate network
all you need to do is set up a vm in
your data center and it will replicate
all the data between aws and your site
it's a cheap way of actually expanding
your storage
so that's pretty much it uh what it is
is basically a service that replicates
data from one point
uh either is your uh
on-prem
um on-prem or aws aws
you can actually have it both ways so if
you decide that i want my data from
on-prem to fly towards aws you can set
up this way or you for example think
about migration and you want to wanna
you know
that's the process if you think about
migration you take your data from the
on-prem here but you might have a system
that is hybrid you might have a system
that is partially hosted in aws and also
partly hosted in your on-prem in which
case uh the storage gateway is awesome
because it syncs the files between those
two locations which means that if
whatever your application is using on
aws connects here
all the data will be exactly the same
here and if you have another bit of
application that's connected here engine
is data that means that it will sync
directly and that's all
with a storage gateway i have a question
um
if we talk about storage which means s3
bucket yes
that exactly is s3 when we're talking
about storage we always
uh pretty much almost always talk about
s3 what it is it actually you point this
to s3
and network s3 is being replicated by
this particular uh
service all the way to your on-prem and
that's pretty much it it's no
uh user interaction it's fully automated
and everything goes over the internet
you can also have a vpn you can have it
that we collect which we're gonna speak
about this later so
there it is
let's let's move on to the next one
so
now we reach the section of the
databases which some of you might be
very very familiar with as i know from
introduction which is absolutely amazing
now
in databases we're going to have a
services like rds which is a relational
database service we're going to have
dynamo which is a managed no sql
database elastic cache we have a
redshift and dms which is the managed
database migration service itself um
all of those are falling under the
database and i would like to discuss
them in a little bit more right now
again i don't want to go into too much
detail that's just basically overview of
what aws has to offer
we're gonna start with
the rds which is known as relational
database service
that provides scalable relational
databases in the cloud through the web
service it manages databases
administrative tags tasks it also
automatically purchases databases
on your behalf
what it actually means
is rds is fully managed database
what it means simple if for example you
have a simple server you have an oracle
you have
any other database pretty much you can
think of
you can have it running on aws
with pretty much the same setup as you
would have on your on-prem there are few
limitations that we will mention during
the um
the more detailed session but
everything around
rds is fully managed and that's
important all you need to do is connect
to the database and start uploading
queries and and read and write and all
of this
as a lds you don't have access to the
os you don't have access anywhere but
the database port itself that you can
create databases and the reason why iws
did that is because they fully manage
that they allow you they they basically
patch the whole thing for you they allow
you to do lots of other things around it
but because it's fully managed they
restrict you from doing specific things
all you need to do is basically connect
and start using the database itself
so
next type of the database
sorry not
next service that aws provides under the
database um
um section is aws migration service it's
basically
a
a service that replicates migrates and
converts the existing databases into aws
uh but also funny enough it works other
way as well you can take stuff from aws
and convert this into your on-prem data
center maybe because you want to take a
backup maybe because you want to have a
copy of it somewhere else just for dr
purposes
it actually
it it works both ways
so
what it does
it takes exact copy of the database
and puts this on the aws ids itself
you can also use the service to convert
from an engine like oracle for example
to something like aurora
which is the aws database uh system that
they came up with now
obviously when you're converting stuff
using this tool quite likely
uh you want to make sure that your
application itself uh supports this and
and
i can tell you for sure that running
systems on oracle for example can be
quite expensive expensive as you
probably already know based on your
builds and licenses if you migrate stuff
to our database it's quite likely gonna
be one
tenth
of a cost
of what you're currently running and
because for aurora you pay for minimum
for storage and you also pay for amount
of queries you have rather than for the
system
itself
um
and
pretty much that's it you can convert
this is long but i will give you more
examples of that in the future sections
when we're going to be discussing that
um if it's okay with you
i know that you have lots of questions
here regarding aurora and all this stuff
and and quite likely i i just i just i
just you know hit a gold mine and you
had 110 of the price i want to go there
which is great
but
i would focus on aurora exactly in
aurora section which we're going to
discuss a little bit uh in the future
for this particular at this particular
state i want to maybe skip a little bit
towards the next slide and it's just an
overview
i just gave a little bit of idea let's
skip a little bit more if it's okay with
you
so
another one under the database it's
dynamic dynamodb
what it is is amazon version of nosql
server and if you ever have requirements
for nosql
database you can use dynamodb and that's
pretty much
what it what it is i can i will give you
more examples on that once we actually
reach a dedicated section for that and
i'll give you all the ideas about cost
pricing about how it works and about
pretty much all the bells and whistles
it has to offer
let's skip to the next one
next one is
next one is um
branches
okay next one is
um
elasticash amazonasticash is basically
a
a service that runs
in front of the database you can put it
in front and act as a cache
what it is is if you have
a users a website and and those
particular users are actually
requesting the same stuff over and over
again from the cloud
yeah
from the server and this server connects
to the database let's say
every single time someone connects to
the web server and server requests stuff
from the database
it basically runs a query and the
queries are kind of going all the way
around now the database itself
is
not necessarily designed
to do
hundreds of thousands of instant
requests and and if you want to keep the
cost down definitely you don't you don't
want to use beefy server because it will
cost you a lot so what you can do is use
a service called amazon elastic which
actually sits exactly here and all of
the requests are going through it
which means if someone already requested
that information it will be cast in the
memory here which means the data only
travels here and it actually never goes
there
and obviously if the query goes
there's some new query that is not
cached here it will pull the query all
the way from the server cache it more
here and that service here is extremely
quick and extremely cheap as well which
means your database at the back end can
be super small and most of the queries
in fact about 80 of the queries that
nowadays lots of systems are doing can
be fully cached which means for a single
query you only need a single request up
until this cast and then everything is
served it's fully automated as well and
you pay only for uh for amount of
queries you have
hence cost saving so which is great
i'll move on to the next slide okay with
you guys
another one is redshift um it's
basically
an amazon data warehousing service and
basically all i'm gonna say right now
is that you can store
huge amount huge amounts of data across
multiple databases across multiple
systems
and and you can then process the data
with some smart technology behind that
i'm not going to give you too much
detail right now because we will
dig into this in the future sessions so
that's just overview of what's to come
so
now we're gonna do some knowledge checks
i hope that you listen and you remember
a few things so if you did
let's go for it question one what is aws
service what aws service is used to run
docker
is it a
elastic bin stock is it b
ec2 container is it c lambda or is it d
direct connect
i can have quite a few answers already
and i can see every single person
answered b
easy to continuously check that's
correct absolutely great listen guys i
don't i don't think you need to do this
course anymore i think you know it all
so you know that's absolutely 100 spot
on great let's move to another question
what is the amazon no sql product called
is it called res is it called dms is it
called redshift or is it called dynamodb
i can see the answers flowing
and the answer
is
d that's correct pretty much i mean you
know what everyone answer d
uh that's that's incredible you know it
all
another question
what service would you use to archive
data for long term storage would you use
glacier
would you use snowball
would you use s3 or would you use
storage gateway
answers are flowing
the correct answer
is a and i see that
one person made them i'm sorry sorry yes
my mistake you you did not do any you
didn't do a mistake you corrected it
that's correct for long time term
a data archive as i mentioned before you
always use glacier why because it's
simply the cheapest and it's a long-term
storage which means you don't need to
access it pretty much
frequently that's great everyone
answered this correctly again i'm i'm
i'm actually impressed it's awesome
so
next section
is
network
in this section we we're gonna have a
little bit about
sorry my mistake uh in this section
we're gonna have a little bit of uh a
vpc we're gonna have a direct connect
and we're gonna have route 53 i can
assure you that at least vpc and route
53 are the services that you're gonna
use pretty much all the time
in a medium major organizations or even
bigger
you will always use direct connect and
i'm gonna explain why in a few seconds
once we while we reach the the
particular slide so let's go for it
so
vpc
vpc stands for virtual private cloud
what it is it's a virtual data center
and works as a bridge between user and
existing infrastructure
on
aws cloud
what it is it's a safe place and secure
place and the most
probably known is the private place that
you pretty much store all your resources
in so all the servers all the databases
all the security rules everything you
can think of is contained within vpc
i can explain from technical point of
view what it is
think of vpc and maybe not everyone will
understand that but from networking
point of view what vpc is it's basically
a vlan
what vlan is is a
dedicated network
for all your resources
on
a switch let's say you have a switch in
the office
and you have display switch works
between let's say two departments
and there are lots of boxes here those
are ports yes i know it's not ideal
sorry for that
and those
ports
uh working with department we have let's
say finance department
and then we have another department that
is maybe i don't know maybe media
and someone decided that both networks
between those two must be fully
independent and they're not shared which
means nobody from media should see what
is in violence and nobody from finance
should see what is in media for some
reason
in this case what maybe network
administrator would do is create two
vlans maybe if you are number one and
maybe build a number two
and whatever is within the vlan itself
is only available to these particular
users within the video and what is
available in this one is only available
to those people so
to recap vpc is basically a container or
a network container around every single
thing you will ever launch into ppc
sorry into aws cloud
and
you can have a multiple vlans so you can
have multiple vpcs depending on what
kind of structure you want to do and
we're going to give you lots of examples
in the future why would you want to have
multiple ones and what are maybe the
issues with that or maybe what are the
processes in one what are maybe the
limitations as well
um
and nobody else except you and all the
resources
have access to this particular bpc so
everything within is secured and it's
private
um i i see question here is trunking
also done
like villains
um yes and no now the vpc itself is a
managed service and when you mean
trunking i presume you mean linking two
vpcs between each other
um it's doable and we call it dpc
peering in the bpc so if you have a vpc
one
and bpc2
you can basically create a link between
them
and that is called vpc peering and you
can say i want that particular vpc to be
able to talk to this particular bpc and
that
is fully connected and working together
um
i can see loads and loads of technical
questions flowing now and i knew we're
gonna have that
um
i will say
i will give you all those technical
answers
in the next
few sessions that we're gonna have
because we're gonna focus on the vpc in
a much better level i know we can
honestly i know we can sit and talk
maybe a week about the vpc and how
different technologies and how different
features actually work here
but it would be easier and quicker for
all of us to just contain this
information and
move it to the session that actually
will discuss dpc directly up until then
it's just basically a first lesson for
everyone to understand more or less what
systems we have and what services we
have and i think we're gonna move on a
little bit and i think we need to speed
up a little bit to be able to finish
today's session on time
so sorry if i can answer your question
right now but keep this question i'm
gonna answer this on the session once we
come near the vpc itself
i hope this is okay with you
so
another service is called
route 53. if you think of route 53
what it is
it's basically a dns
it's a amazon dns and
you can register domains with the router
63 you can host multiple domains and and
records in there and
you can have it geo um you can have a
geo dns which means you can have it
worldwide um
and it's
it's basically dns as a service that's
all you need to know at the moment
and
we're gonna focus on that in the more
detail
session
later on um
and that's pretty much what what i
wanted to do and say about 163 for for
now
another one is called direct connect
direct connect is a basically
a way of connecting uh your resources
into the aws environment so imagine
situation you have
uh your data center or your on premise
and you have a bunch of servers sitting
there
all you want to do is basically expand
your network of using aws resources all
you're going to do is create a aws
direct connect there are other ways of
doing that don't get me wrong you can do
you can do vpn and you can also use the
internet just like that but direct
connect is the quickest
shortest and the least latency uh
solution out there because it actually
maps with your
data center
and also mpls connection so basically
your list line directly to aws resources
which means you're going on the shortest
possible route into the aws
and it's extremely stable you do pay for
it a little bit get me wrong it's not
cheap and it's not free definitely but
if you work in the big organizations all
of them are using direct connect because
it speeds things up
um uh i have a question can we have a
simple high level picture showing a
position slash boxes of a ws components
if uh
learned till now like an example diagram
um if application is hosted in aws
um
and is this particular question anka
regarding the direct connect
no it's all the components till now
meaning how we will
the picture look okay actually i'm gonna
know this question right now for you and
what i'm gonna do is once we finish
today i will come back and i'll um
draw this little duel of mine to explain
this but i really wanted to finish the
the session first and then i can answer
your question in the last uh 50 minutes
of our time for today i will be able to
to explain a little bit more so sorry if
i can answer this right now i do not
forget that and if i do please remind me
by the end of this i will be more than
happy to do for you
on my screen so let me
switch to the next one
now
another one
is another section we have today is
called analytics and in analytics we
have emr we have a data pipe we have
elastic search we have kinesis and we
have machine learning um since the
uh reinvent last week they introduced
few new ones
um
and then this is probably a little bit
longer than that but for the exam you
only need to know quite a few of those
and i'll go through through all of those
and with you guys one by one
um
um what media i have another question
from umash what media use in
uh
case of direct connect
i don't i don't understand the question
uh what do you mean by media umash
um
ah what internet um
okay
basically
coming back to the slide before just to
answer um a question is basically uh
what internet
uh is used in between now
aws has appearing agreements with all
the biggest tier one um providers in the
world which that's why they are so
pretty much present in all the 190
countries which means they bought a huge
data links in between
shortest possible routes in between the
data centers and all the premises pretty
much you can think of any location in
the world
when you purchase aws direct connect
that means that they will link you via
their own link and guarantee the
bandwidth you're actually buying so
basically it's like almost losing a
lease line between the data center and
aws
it's unthrottled basically there's no
limit to it
and it's extremely quick because it's
peered directly between the data center
and aws resources and it's the quickest
and the shortest way possible for you to
get the data
so i hope i answer your question there
is no
internet provider that prefer depends on
the country so they have different
agreements of different countries
depending on what is present there and
who is the best as simple as this
but it's a very valid question let's
move
on
so
um
actually i have another question can we
say it's like express root link
yes um
basically it you can it is exactly the
same uh the same thing in azure you call
it a express route in ams you call it
direct connect so it's exactly the same
so
next session
in analytics we have a service called
elasticsearch
it allows you to use the popular open
source search and analytics engine as a
managed service on aws
and that's pretty much the description
of the service i'll give you all the
information about it
in the future when we actually focus
directly onto this um
that's that's all it is to it
another one elastic map reduce
what it is it's allow businesses and
developers to process large amounts of
data using a hardwood framework it is
useful for process like data mining and
scientific simulation
now
i can
say that um elastic map reduce
is is not the most popular service of
aws
and
because simply most of the time you're
going to work
based on your experience um
you're going to be working with
everything but emr so elastic mapreduce
what is actually used for is to take
petabytes of data from different sources
and analyze it in a in a in a in a
massive ways and what it is it's it's
actually spinning up huge amounts of
servers
and links them together and by the hydro
itself cluster allows you to do specific
uh operations and have specific output
like scientific simulations or maybe
parsing or all of that
but
i worked for huge organizations in the
world and pretty much enterprises pretty
much for past uh 15 years and i can tell
you that nobody ever wants to go near
this because there was never a need for
that
um they always have some sort of tool
that passes the data in some sort of way
but that is designed for huge
simulations like nasa is trying to maybe
compute something and they upload
hundreds of databases of data so quite
likely for us humans we'll never reach
this level and um
that's pretty much what i can say about
that we'll pretty much go to this in
auditor in the future
now another one
we have service called kinesis it's a
way of streaming data to aws
kinesis can ingest lots of data very
quickly from a mobile app let's say from
the sensors and other what it is is
basically
it's a collector or connector that you
can push loads of data into the kinesis
itself it absorbs all the data from
different sources and you can basically
process this data in some sort of way
and pretty much that's it that's that's
all the information at this kind of
stage i can i can give you more to come
another one
it's machine learning
now that's a scary thing it's like the
machines will take over the world right
now what it is
um
it's basically
uh can this particular service can
predict the future behavior from
existing data for problems like fraud
detection and
or people that bought x number of things
uh or both why
uh
a number of things so amazon actually a
website so the store is using
their service this despicable service
through machine learning
to be able to determine how many things
people are buying and how many things we
need to order for specific times over
for the season for example
and
let's say you have a a a
christmas sale or a black friday which
we recently had and they know that
particular phone let's say samsung
galaxy s7 edge or whatever else we have
out there right now
it's gonna be a hot hit because everyone
will buy it they use this particular
algorithm to determine how many of those
they need to order in stock
in order to be most profitable obviously
they don't want to overstock it because
they're going to pay for the warehouse
and they might be able to sell it but
they don't want to under order it
which means they're going to sell out
they're not going to make profit so they
use this service and it's awesome which
we're going to go through a more in
detail in the future and you can
actually teach the machine of different
behaviors and patterns
and you can actually you know use it to
predict specific things obviously
you could even go as far as predicting
the tomorrow lottery numbers i i i'm
pretty sure there are people out there
trying to do that
i'm not sure if it's going to be as
accurate and 100 because i'm sure there
are projects and people use it before
i'm giving an example of what you could
do
just just a little seed in your in your
in your in your empty empty pot so you
can actually
think of different scenarios and how you
can use it
another one
it's called quickside
it's what it is it's a fast cloud power
based business intelligence service that
makes it easy for all employees to build
a visualization perform ad hoc analytics
and quickly get the business insight
from their data
so
basically you can
get files you can get data sources and
anything else and you can build charts
and some sort of bi intelligent systems
that will actually visualize the data in
some sort of way so imagine situation
that you have an excellent spreadsheet
and in excel spreadsheet you keep your
sales and every single day when the
sales happens they you can keep adding
them into the into the line and in this
case um we could actually say that that
line is number of days and that line is
number of sales
and in this case the the the quick side
class you go through your exo fetch all
the rows that much in a particular day
and put show you on the visualize how
many services you made and that's pretty
much as a service so i know you can do
this in the actual um charts and you can
do the same thing i gave you an idea
more or less how it works and you can
also obtain the information from a
databases you can obtain from from
pretty much
you salesforce you can link it pretty
much every way if you think about it so
it's actually awesome it's currently in
the in in a it recently came out from
beta uh i think last week and now it's
fully ga which means you can start
testing it and and and have fun with it
so that's that's pretty much quickside
let me hide this and let's go to a last
one
it's called data pipeline
what it is
it's used to extract transform and load
data from other locations into aws you
can schedule the activity and get alerts
in case it fails so
basically
yes you can leave your computer running
24 7 just to have access to your file on
the on the nas that's great but you
cannot say that the computer will be
running 24 7 because you might have a
power loss you might lose
i don't know
hard drive might fail something might
happen on the computer itself in this
case you can use a data pipeline as a
service itself that can fetch the data
and actually transform extract and do
lots of other things and put it into aws
itself it's very handy tool and we'll
discuss this more in the future
so we reached the
enterprise applications
that particular
uh
depletion section consists of a
workspaces consists of workdogs and work
mail what it is is basically a fully
managed
environment for you to use um
where workspaces workdogs and mail
is basically environments you work on
and i'm going to give you some ideas in
the next slide
so amazon workdogs
what it is is basically
think of it as enterprise dropbox used
to share all your documents with your
colleagues
it creates a single
basic dropbox that you can share with
all the friends and colleagues and and
and
pretty much everyone can link to it and
you can use it as pretty much like a
sharepoint except it's a storage rather
than the website itself um so yeah
that's pretty much what it is
another one is called work mail it's
amazon's answer to exchange you can
provide everyone in your company with
the same email system and calendar now
we all know exchange we all know how big
it is and how complex it is and if you
ever manage the exchange you know how
pain on the bum it is
especially once you reached a big size
and you have multiple systems multiple
servers and and all you're trying to do
is is basically manage this work
amazon workmail is basically a
simplified version of exchange is
basically exchanged as a service which
is awesome because all you need to do is
other users and that's the extent of
your administrative tasks which means
the rest of the time you can sit through
the desk and absolutely nothing and say
you're managing the work uh email server
which is absolutely great yes there are
other services for example like office
365 you can use as well but obviously
that's not part of this particular
session i'm just giving you an idea of
what amazon workmail is
in in compared to
another one
is called workspaces
workspaces is an enterprise application
that gives you
as a standard windows desktop that you
can control remotely so think of it as
remote the remote desktop environment
for your or your work colleagues that
you have
let's say you have a company that is
many different business like many
different offices around the world and
all of those people uh want to use
pretty much the same system access and
access the same desktops and have pretty
much the same policies around what
normally you would do is yes you can
have a system administrator in every
single of those places to manage that
you can do this remotely if you want but
you can actually use workspaces and what
it is it's basically creating a windows
2012 remote desktop session and all of
that can be linked for example with
services like s3 or you can use other
services that you can actually copy the
data from and have access to which means
no matter the location of the user uh
they all feel like they're in the same
office yet they're scattered around the
world we use this quite a bit it's
pretty good um it does have limitations
which we will be able to talk about this
in the next probably a few sessions but
that's just more or less the overview
for this one for now
now your favorite knowledge base uh
let's go for it
where does route 53 get its name from
route 53
is a 53 is the port on the dns it uses
from
53 available aws routes
it does not have specific name
significant significance
on average the ping latency between aws
resources is 53 milliseconds
i can see the answers flowing that's
great keep it coming keep it coming
okay pretty much everyone
answered
a
exactly
uh i only have uh one answer c which is
it doesn't have specific significance
yeah you could potentially go for this
answer i understand why but actually
if you ever work with the dns you know
it's using port 53 which is the most
famous report for that and
um obviously that's the correct answer
so remember root 53 gets its name from a
port it's actually using pretty much
everyone got the response
congratulations another question which
servers allows you to stream data into
aws is it a elastic mapreduce is it b
quickside is it c kinesis or is it the
data pipeline
that's a tricky tricky i see different
answers interesting
okay i see a
lot of different answers
okay okay okay
so
the correct answer is c
kinesis allows you to stream large
amounts of data into aws from mobile
apps or sensors
so no worries if you answered wrong that
is absolutely fine we are here to learn
we are here to discuss this we are here
to actually improve and by the end of
this session you already know that the
correct answer for this particular
question is kinesis and by the end of
the whole all the sessions you'll be
you'll be able to answer this question
on the exam and get your certification
so no worries about the wrong answers
because they're not really the wrong
answers we are all here to learn that's
absolutely great
another question
which of those is not an aws enterprise
application is it a
workbox is it b word a workmail is it c
work server is a d
workspaces
i can see the answers flowing
it looks like everyone is doing copy
paste copy paste the same answer it's
absolutely amazing yes it's c
work server is not part of the
enterprise application everything else
is
it's a hundred percent guess correct
now
now we're gonna go for mobile services
let's skip that slide and go straight
into it
so
i'm gonna speed up a bit because we have
about 20 minutes to finish this
particular session and i still have a
few things to go
so i will try my best
amazon cognito what it is and what it
does basically saves mobile users data
into aws if you're ever working with the
application the
deployment and you ever using a mobile
as your as your as your um
application basically a host you
probably will want to use cognito
because it allows you to
it will allow you to stream all your
data into aws code itself
another one mobile service
mobile sales service analytics tracks
and measures up in-app activity which
means if you have a mobile app you'll be
able to have analytics based on that
imagine google analytics on the mobile
in the aws form that's what it is
now amazon simple notification service
also known as
sns
what it does it sends mobile
notifications emails and sms messaging
based
on
different scenarios so for example if
you have a situation that
you want to send user a specific um i
don't know maybe text message because
they just sign up for your um
service
you can use amazon sns and provide with
sms the message as well as the mobile
number and it will do it for you it can
be fully automated it can be it can be
linked with many other things and in
fact lots of other servers service
providers are using it as yell periscope
and tinder
so another one
aws device form
what it is and what it does it allows
you to test all your applications on the
bunch of different ios and android
devices in the same
time what it means is you don't need to
have hundreds of different mobiles on
your desktop anymore to be able to test
this you all all you need to do is
upload the application and run and click
run button and it will run through every
single possible scenario and it will
tell you which devices will have an
issue i don't have to tell you how
important it is and how quick that is
because allows you to actually exclude
all the possibilities all of the issues
without actually having physical devices
it's absolutely awesome
another one is called aws mobile hub
builds allows you to test and monitor
mobile apps basically it's like a
sandbox for you to start building your
applications
in one place and basically publish this
as well
another section we came now is called
iot
i i remember we had a question about iot
and we're going to get to this uh in the
in the in the in the uh class as well i
don't think we're gonna have a
question on the exam about that but it's
good to know what iot is and why we're
gonna use it so
iot
itself edwards iot
is internet of things is a managed cloud
platform that that lets
connected devices such as cars light
bulbs sensors and other things interact
with the cloud
now recently you had a lot of things
like smart houses like smart lion bulbs
like smart pretty much everything you
can think of it's pretty much smart now
iot allows you to basically create
different recipes different scenarios
and based on that
control different devices and have a
different behavior it's kind of a little
bit of future and it's kind of a little
bit of awesome
and you'll probably want to research
this
a little bit more
and you will see
the possibilities of that are endless
just to give you a rough idea for
example you can have a light in the
house
connected to iot and you can specify
if the sunset goes down or if there's a
sunset for example turn on the lights in
my house and it will do that you can
have another one saying for example if
if i'm away from home
turn on the lights so when you leave the
house device will come on and that's
that's the thing you can control devices
from uh from iws iot because you can
create those recipes and create those
logical uh behaviors that you can apply
to different devices
now another one is
basically develop developer tools
we have code commits we have a code
deploy and code pipeline i'll go through
them very quickly if i may
code commit allows you to create aws
hosted version control for your code
it's basically like a version of a
github based on
aws it is basically a github allows you
to basically pull from all those places
and deploy
and distort in the s3
another one
uh
through
also aws called deploy you can get your
code from code commit repository and
deploy it to your ec2 instances which
means you can have multiple versions of
your code and using the
cloud commit
sorry code commit
you'll be able to deploy all the stuff
directly to your servers so it's a fully
automated
repository that you can use
in elastic environment
sorry
and the last but not least is a code
pipeline
what code pipeline is
what aws code python is is a continuous
delivery service of fast and
reliable application updates
code pipeline builds tests and deploys
your code every time there is a code
change based on the release process
models you define
now that service on its own is what
every single
devop guy pretty much loves and wants to
hear is the service that when you call
change the code it redeploys this code
on the new environment or on the current
environment and changes everything for
you so it's instantly available if you
want to that means you don't need to
ever spend hundreds of hours sitting and
updating every single server in the
directors because you want to make sure
that the data is exactly the same in
fact doing that quite likely you're
gonna skip through service and quite
like you're gonna have a different data
within a few minutes because we're just
humans and we make mistakes especially
after you've done this 99 times on 99
boxes and this 100 will have a different
code and suddenly nothing is the same
with the code pipeline you'll be able to
automate this and make it exactly the
same every single time so save time save
money
knowledge check
now which service allows you to save
mobile user data in aws cloud is it a
cognito is it b sns is it c device farm
or is it the
mobile hub
still waiting for a few answers
okay the answers are in
and the correct answer is a i can see
pretty much everyone
uh answered a that's great few people
answered b and d
which can be confusing yes device form
sounds like something you want to store
the data but in this particular case
we're using cognito which is exactly
saving mobile user data in aws cloud no
worries if you answered wrong
now you know the correct answer so don't
worry about that
now which aws service is used as a code
repository
is it a call deploy is it b code commit
is it c called pipeline or is it d
lambda
still waiting for few answers
okay the answers are in the correct
answer is b pretty much everyone
answered b and if you didn't
don't worry about it
all sounds pretty much the same
again now you know the correct answer
and feel free if if you're not sure you
can always feel free to go to all those
documents and read it again and also
watch all the videos and you understand
why it's this particular answer
now
aws management console and we have
management tools here we have a multiple
different sub sub sections we have a
cloud world we have a transformation
cloud trail and few others which i'm
gonna go with you just about now
so starting with the cloud watch enables
monitoring of ec2 and other amazon cloud
services so you can get alerts when
error occurs or when aws service
disconnects
basically it's a monitoring service that
monitors every single resource on aws
it's fully integrated with aws it
monitors pretty much all the metrics of
aws
the reason why it's being deployed is
because physically you have no access to
your servers physically you don't know
you cannot log in
you can log into the box and check from
the os or you have other metrics that
you cannot
and aws itself uh especially cloudwatch
allows you to monitor
every single metrics you can think of
second cloud formation
cloud formation allows you to set up a
bunch of
uh connected aws services together
basically
cloud formation allows you to
predefine
resources that you want
and put it in a code so imagine
situation i want
to deploy
a web server and the database
and i want this particular behavior or
this particular pattern to happen
multiple times because i want to deploy
this everywhere in the world in the same
way
what i would do is i will create a
single cloud formation
template
and this bucket template will specify i
want the web server that is ec2 i want
the databases ids i want this size i
wanted this number of megabytes of
storage or gigabytes i want many
different things
and with this backup template you can
basically deploy
that in every single region in exactly
the same way all you need to do is copy
this template and copy paste copy paste
launch and you're going to have exactly
the same environment in every single
location
that's what cloud formation is we're
gonna know more about it in the
following
sessions
next one
cloud trail
cloud trail audits users activity on
your aws resources
basically every single action that you
ever take
either via aws console or via the api
because aws console actually is a pretty
interface that is using api anyway
is being logged and you can enable this
by default it's not enabled but you can
enable this particular service cloud
tray itself and it will log every single
activity for every single
resource that aws is uh actually uh you
you launched if you spin in your server
it will be locked if you deleted the
server it will be logged if you just
logged on it will be logged so it's a
very good point for auditing and seeing
what actually
went wrong maybe someone deleted
something you can go back to the log and
you can see it
aws config
basically database config keeps track of
configuration management changes in my
situation you want your
system or your environment to look in
the way you design that and you have
multiple people
working with you and all of them have
access to your resource you cannot spend
all day long looking at people hands and
making sure that they are not changing
anything and what you would do is deploy
aws config that remembers the
configuration and if anything changes
you will be the first person to know
about it
ops works
what ops works is is help to configure
and manage operations using chef if you
ever worked with a deployment
quite likely most of you did chef is
automated orchestration and
automation tool that allows you to
perform lots of different actions and
ops works actually integrates it it
actually integrates with check and
allows you to do specific actions
that's what i would say at this
particular stage because that's just
overview more will to come will be to
come
another one is called service catalogs
catalog gives you other gives other aws
users in your group access to
presets up that you build
now
basically
that's all you need to know catalog
gives access to other users with the
presets and that's all i have to say at
this stage we're gonna know more about
it in the next
more detailed
section
now trusted advisor it's a very very
interesting concept that adw did and
what it is is automated services that
identifies areas where you have uh where
you're paying access uh for your aws
resources something like for example aws
ec2 instances and a few others it has
four uh sections cost optimizing
performance security and fault tolerance
if you think of aws you would think that
all they want to do is make money and to
some degree it's true
but what they've done is
and how they want to be seen is that
they're trying to save you money that
you pay per hour and then they don't
want you to spin up those boxes for too
long and what aws trusted advisor is is
a tool that you can run across whole
account and it will go through optimism
of optimizing your account based on the
cost based on the performance and maybe
if you have security issues it will go
through that as well and it will flag
any potential issues just if you have
idea
you
you have developer box that you just
spun up and developer is working on it
that's great
and then developer finished working on
it and
the box is still running guess what
you're still paying for it because
you're paying for every single hour if
you run this trusted advisor maybe
weekly or monthly it's up to you it will
be able to tell you hey this particular
box seemed that there's no much traffic
to it and i would actually recommend
shutting it down
to save money and you can actually take
action also if you spin up the box that
is way too big for what he's actually
doing and he's using maybe like five
percent of cpu rather than you know 50
this particular tool will tell hey i
actually noticed the test this
particular server it's not being used
much i actually recommend scanning it
down maybe a notch or two so making it
smaller this way you'll be able to save
money and security as well hey i noticed
you have a port open which is pretty
much open to the internet are you sure
you really want to have your ssl sorry
an ssh or a remote desktop open and
we'll flag it straight away it's very
good tool i highly encourage to use it
now one of the
last ones is security and identity
okay
i'm gonna jump straight into the
slides
um identity and access manager
management also known as i am
allows you to set up
additional users you can generate new
keys set up policies and everything else
you can think of think of it as active
directory
think of it as as
any authentication that allows any user
within your organization to login to aws
resources
now you can use uh ions to create users
you can create groups you can assign
different permissions different users or
groups you can have multi-factor
authentication based on your policies
different things let's just overview all
of that will come
another one amazon inspector
what amazon inspector is it installs
agents on your ec2 instances and scans
items set up to determine its security
think of it as a security
daemon that runs on all your instances
and
if it detects some abnormal behavior
you'll be able to have reports straight
about this or if there's a specific
bridge because there's a specific
produce you'll be actually notified
straight away
not many people are using that um
because they have internal systems that
kind of they use like cementec or or or
sofas or whatever else you use that's
great you can try to use this it's
pretty awesome and it's fully integrated
with aws itself
another one called aws cloud
hsm service helps you to meet corporate
contractual and regulation compliance
requirements by
securing um by actually introducing
hardware security module into appliances
for all
the
resources you have
so for example imagine you need to have
um additional security for your
encryption keys you need to have
additional security for
encryption and uh for for data
encryption
you quite likely will manage this
through hsm more about this in the
future
section
now next one aw directory service make
it it makes it easy to set up and run
microsoft active directory in the aws
cloud
allows you to connect to aws resources
with existing on-prem microsoft active
directory
basically you will be able to extend
your active directory into the aws cloud
yes you can achieve exactly the same
thing by having an additional server
running on the ec2 running additional ad
and you can link on-prem with this
particular server
and that's maybe how you want to extend
it but there are a few services like
even rds that do not support ad itself
because a limited service and in order
for you to have let's say a sql server
authenticating against your id which
lots of probably you do then you need to
integrate it with aws directory service
that connects to your id and links with
audios itself that's just rough idea
another one aws key management service
also known as kms is managed service
that makes it easy for you to create and
control encryption keys used to encrypt
all your data it's using basically
hardware security modules um
to protect all of your security keys
you can actually
upload your own keys that you you have
into aws and aws will act like a storage
for all your keys and those keys can be
used to encrypt specific data for your
storage or for access to any other
resource and you can also generate new
keys
with amazon twitch is exactly the same
another one is called web application
firewall
it blocks bad requests to cloud phone
protects your site it's actually
amazon's attempt of blocking lots of um
unnecessary traffic towards your website
and saving your money and maybe making
it sure that your website's up and
running and and preventing from
something like uh um a little bit of a
ddos and i wouldn't say massive details
because it's probably not gonna block it
because there's probably nothing that
can but
uh it can
do lots of protection like uh sequel
injections it's like sniffers like
scrapers it can pretty much take care of
that block the traffic and only users
that are supposed to access your website
are actually able to do so
and
probably the last one on the list
yes on the list is application services
uh
that i have a question regarding the
s web application firewall does it do
intrusion detection the answer is
it kind of does
but it's simplified don't think of it as
a as a fully blown um intrusion
detection system that is capable of
lending different things it's using
simple simple patterns and that are
being pretty much added and every single
day
and if you want to read more about what
it can do i would actually go to adaf's
website to aws waft so waf and see what
extent it can do that's probably the
best source of getting your information
on that
uh so last last bunch of slides is about
the application services we have an
application api gateway which is the
proxy which basically
would process your api so you can
throttle back client traffic test new
versions and process methods more
cleanly so basically you can
write your own
apis and call apis
externally and it will allow you to
route your traffic to specific places so
basically think of it as
manage api service
upstream upstream let's let you deliver
your windows applications to any device
if you for example have
multiple devices like mobile tablet and
client it can be windows mac or linux
doesn't really matter it will allow you
to stream your apps directly into those
devices so if in your organization for
example you have an app that you wrote
and you want to push this towards
everyone or even update probably
upstream is the place to be and and
service to use because it will allow you
to easily stream this automatically to
all those devices
cloud search
um what it is is amazon's full
text search service
that's pretty much all i want to say at
this current stage allows you to search
through any data based on your s3 or
maybe any database in this particular
case uh amazon dynamo it's basically
think of it as a kind of
almost an index of all your files on s3
and dynamo
elastic transcoder it's basically a
service that allows you to transcode the
media from a single
format into the multiple formats to be
delivered to multiple devices i know
it's being used a lot uh think of it as
as maybe a youtube and although it's not
really youtube but think of it like that
you upload your source which can be
recorded in let's say 4k but then
someone is watching the stream on the
iphone or on the tablet and that market
tool or a device doesn't actually allow
you to watch the 4k what it will do it
will stream down and
compress the media to actually fit the
particular device and it does this on
the fly and all you need to pay is
basically for time you use it nothing
else
simple email service
uh also known as
ses allows you to send one
um
or many
emails like a marketing emails password
resets and notifications and basically
it's a must email service that amazon
provides um
that's pretty much it
simple queue service also known as sqs
is a hosted queue that integrates uh
sorry increases the workflow between
distributed components and applications
that perform different tasks imagine
situation that you have and
different users and those users um have
um
a lot of different tasks and you have
one server that can perform those tasks
instead of all those users throwing all
those requests to the server itself uh
you can actually put them in the queue
and then server fetches the
last one actually the oldest one in the
queue for example and processes them um
based on the order rather than
everything at once
so that's basically it
amazon
amazon uses simple workflow service also
known as swff
and it's warehouses what it does it
basically allowing
uh
um it's allowing to create a specific
workflows that are most efficient and
imagine situation that you have all
those orders around the
um and around the around the amazon uh
store and all those orders uh consist of
specific products and those products are
actually based on shelves across the
data
across across the the
the shelves in the in the in in the
storage
and it will allow
to create a workflow that is the most
efficient uh to get from a to b to c to
d
in the least amount of stacks to be able
to fetch all those uh products into the
basket
to actually complete the order so
basically that's pretty much it
you